all right um
welcome everyone to the ddpsm now
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over some rules and
logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk unless you have
questions if you have questions you are
welcome to unmute and ask
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in q a session at the end
second today's
today's ddps seminar is open to external
audiences therefore no classified
discussion is allowed so please watch
out
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our youtube channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today all right
it is an honor to host ming zhang who is
currently an assistant research
scientist in the texas a m institute of
data science at the texas a m university
he works closely with ulysses
braga natto simon uh boccard and many
others on the algorithmic and theoretic
developments of scientific machine
learning
before his positions at um you know
institute of data science in texas a m
he
worked as a postdoc postdoctoral
researcher at the johns hopkins
university with mauro magioni on
data-driven modeling of
self-organization from observation
he obtained his ph.d in applied
mathematics under the guidance of
athens
ted moore at the university of maryland
today ming will give a talk about
machine learning of self organizations
from observations please expect a
wonderful talk and
and and please enjoy it and now without
further ado let me pass the button to me
by asking our usual question that is
what is your favorite things to do other
than research mean
uh
coding in python
well that's part of research oh oh
okay uh uh oh right now i'm trying to
lose some weight so uh yeah going to
jinx yes
going to gym okay
that sounds healthy okay the stage is
yours
thank you uh thank you dr choi for the
introduction it is my pleasure and also
honor today to be able to share with you
my uh uh years of research at job
shopkins which is about how to combine
machine learning and a dynamical system
together so that we can do this data
driven modeling of self organization
oh sorry that's the path so here's an
outline of my talk i'm gonna give you a
brief motivation on how
we're gonna why we're gonna combine
machine learning and dynamical system
together and then after that i'll give
you a detailed framework on how to learn
self-organization for data and then
after that i'll go through a several
simple extensions on how to extend our
learning framework to various different
dynamic systems and then uh the fourth
session we'll talk about how to actually
apply our learning framework to actual
data to to to um real data and how to
overcome this difficulty of learning
from real data
and then at the end i will talk about
two ongoing projects we are actually
making pretty good progress with it and
some future directions we are taking
with this approach
so um here is uh demotivation uh we want
to so you all know that machine learning
is really good at recognizing patterns
and there are actually a lot of
interesting patterns that arise
naturally in the world for example these
static strike patterns on zebra
patterns doesn't need to be static all
the time even this is relatively static
in a relative spacing this v formulation
from this flocking of birds
or even this you have a static shape but
all the position i've already announced
that it is the freckle shape forming
from this milling of fish
and these pattern doesn't need to be uh
standard in space it can be static in
other extra space say for example this
frequency space you have this
synchronization of clocks okay all of
the different interesting patterns we
want to understand that and most
importantly won't be able to predict or
even reproduce these patterns so we need
to understand what caused these patterns
and all of this can be put under the
banner of so-called self-organization
so where a global order will emerge from
initially chaotic state
via only local interactions so you only
need local interactions and you have
some kind of global order and it happens
a lot you have it in crystal growth
superconductivity
you've seen this in chemistry for this
molecular self-assembly you already seen
some of these flocking of birds and
other social behavior in insects and in
human society you have this market uh
economy behavior and traffic flow you
can see that all over the place okay if
you understand this you can apply
abstractly to uh
unsupervised uh learning using the
so-called particle swarm optimization
you can even
use that to analyze consensus how
opinion is from how social behavior of
humans is actually
formed and behave
yeah once you know how intimate
animals interact with each other you can
study the migration of animals and do
conservations of animals and if once you
know how true humans particles
animals are interact you can build that
into robot and do digital trainings
using these bionic interactions so we
want to understand that and most
importantly we want to understand it
from the mathematical point of view we
want to build some kind of math
mechanism to actually explain it okay
and there's a basic really simple
dynamical system mechanism behind it you
use a
interacting agent system to actually
build this self-organization
you just allow these
pairwise interactions between agents you
can have agents of different types you
can have agents when interacting with
the environment but as long as you allow
only paradise interactions you should be
able to reproduce this global behavior
but the most important question is how
to actually model the so-called
interactions between the agents okay
there are many different ways take this
flocking model for example if you want
to
model the interaction between the birds
you will allow this so-called three-zone
principle so when the agents get close
they should repulse when the agents get
really far away they should attract and
in the middle of the interaction range
they should align their headings so this
three zones alignment you can actually
use to model flockings the other
dynamical system that follow different
principles so for potency they have this
self-propelling particle systems
uh for crowds they have the opinion for
consensus formulation of the particle
system okay but what we want to do is
can we actually derive from observation
data say for example i look at how the
birds are actually interacting flying up
in the sky can actually divide the
system to
actually
to actually
give the interaction rules between all
the ages that's what we want to do we
want to develop this system to actually
validate and improve the
self-organization dynamics so that's our
motivations we want to use machine
learning to guide us in order to give us
the organized dynamical system and the
learning framework the next step is
about the learning framework so the
question go back to can i actually learn
the influences from the observational
data okay and most importantly can i
actually derive the dynamic system
which gives some some kind of physical
meaning
and can actually apply our learning
method to as many different dynamic
systems as possible and can my learning
handle big data so it has to be
efficient and effective okay in order to
do that let me start off on a really
really simple dynamical system let's
consider a system of just n agents and
each agent is assigned a state and this
state vector can be used to describe
emotion position velocity
phases etc etc anything that you want
so i want this state the change of this
state vector that is trying to minimize
a certain system energy
okay and this system energy has a really
special form it's just a sum of all the
potential depending on parallel distance
between all the agents
okay and simplifying i have that the
change of the state for each agent is an
average sum of a
interaction function that is based on
pairwise interaction between all the
ages and also weighted by the parent's
difference
okay and we'll call this interaction
function the interaction kernel
okay so the current research will be
starting from annoying class or
regularity requirement for these fees i
can induce desired emergent behavior so
if he is all positive we have the
cluster clustering uh if he's satisfied
some talent we primarily have the
flocking and etc etc okay what we want
to do is
when we take only the observation of the
state and change of this state over a
certain period of time for the whole
system can actually derive the so-called
interaction kernel from observation data
using the inverse formula approach okay
so we want to do that
okay before i tell you the relational
approach let's just assume that my
unknown function live in a really nice
space so that the dynamic system has a
unique and uh
unique solutions and if i and i also
want to compare this to the regression
approach if i put everything into this
one big vector the state vector and also
the right hand side vector i actually
are looking at
finding a right hand side function that
can map the state vector to its
derivative so it looks really really
similar to regression however the state
vector the observation vector they know
they are not independent so we don't
have data independent so we cannot use
the regression approach even if you can
derive some some kind of independence
they are living in a high dimensional
space so you still will be cursed by the
dimensional lab so we want to
tackle these two approaches in actually
analyzing the convergence so we will
take this
continuous data and discretize it and
also we'll consider these trajectory
data coming out of different initial
conditions so now we have a discretized
data from various different initial
conditions and then we will build
a air functional that's trying to
minimize the derivative of the observed
state
to the predicted state on the test
function
okay so if i can have that
then i should be
have something convergent to my annoying
interaction kernel okay and because my
search space is nice it's compact and
complex compared in terms of the l
infinity node and this minimizer would
exist okay but to show the convergence
is rather difficult so let's consider a
uh expected version of my error
functional that the m going to infinity
and then it's really easy to show that
the minimizer of the discretized
air functional will go to this expected
version of various functional okay the
only question would remain is that can i
show that l
v hat l infinity h
is indeed my unknown interaction kernel
if i can show that then i can use large
number to show this convergence and
hence converging to this interaction
kernel okay well in order to show for me
to show this i need an additional
condition on my
inverse problem it's so called a
constant positivity condition which
basically just found the air functional
that i'm trying to minimize by the
distance between the unknown true
interaction question uh function to
the test function
okay using this particular outer routine
this row t actually tells me the
distribution of power distance
okay and with that we're able to show
that the convergence
if i can construct these variable
sequence of fee head element minimizer
for increa ever increasing such space
that will have the conversion of this v
hat to the unknown interaction at the
rate of m to the negative one third
which is very similar to a 1d regression
rate okay and i can also have the
predicted dynamical system converging to
the observed dynamical system the
trajectories okay with roughly the same
rate
okay so my learning rate is depends only
on m the number of uh initial conditions
and is optimal in terms of the 1d
regression
but my learning way of well sorry
binomial doesn't depend on the dimension
of the observation data that's one thing
so even if i have the number of agents
going to infinity or the state getting
really large my array will not
deteriorate however my learning rate
will depending on the number of time i
make a observation that still is still
open program we're still working on that
okay
so now we have a theoretical guarantee
on the convergence of getting the
unknown interactions now we want to talk
about if i can implement this in an
effective algorithm so that i can deal
with a large data set okay so we start
off for this from this discretized
observation data okay we'll compute this
so-called learning interval with this
minimum and maximum interaction radius
between all my agents once i build this
learning interval i can build up on it a
space of basis function which is my
search space using either clamp b spline
or piecewise polynomials anything that
you want
okay
and then after that we'll take the
optimal basis uh dimension of my search
way and uh with the formula that we
calculated for our theory this is
roughly about n to the one-third using
uniform partition we can also use
adaptive prediction but uniform position
would be one of the most easy one to use
and then i will express my express my
search
test function as a linear combination of
this basis function over this search
base and plug into my minimizer
minimization problem
and that i get a linear systems
uh yeah
we'll answer the question chile and then
once i have that once i my theoretical
my convergence theorem guarantees that
the linear system that i attain actually
is really nice the condition number on
this linear system is actually well
controlled
so i can actually solve it to get all
the linear the coefficients for my basis
i can reconstruct my estimator and now
you can use it to predict my
dynamical system and do long-time
behavior analysis on my dynamical
systems okay and in this case i
mentioned that i need the state
observation of the state and the
derivative of the state but in fact we
don't need that as soon as i have a
really good approximation of this
derivative we can still plug in and
obtain a really good estimator out of
this linear system we have a guarantee
on that using rkhs okay
so uh about computational compaction so
uh this algorithm can handle really big
data so in order to for me to talk about
let me just
refresh your memory about all of these
different parameters this ml and d here
okay for computing time the total
computing time is actually roughly m to
the uh five uh three fifths okay so it's
a little bit super linear in terms of
the number of initial conditions but if
you use parallel
algorithm to actually reconstruct the
linear system based on each
different initial conditions you can cut
it down into roughly linear in terms of
m the storage actually you just need to
store one initial condition at uh i mean
one system to exactly at a time and then
construct that save it somewhere and
then do another one so it's still
finally paralyzable and then at the end
it's just roughly n squared and this is
just n to the two thirds so everything
you can use in parallelization you can
cut it into linear and we have a
software package that you can try and
use to reproduce all the results that we
have on these papers and also these
different
dynamical systems okay
also uh just to answer the question in
the chat by dimensional data is is
actually not just the number of agents
it's the number of agents times the
length of each state vector so it's n
times d so the dimension of data is is
uh it's capitality way bigger than just
the number of agents okay so now uh go
back into this so now we can apply this
to this so-called opinion dynamics which
is used to govern how a consensus is
formed
so this blue line is actually the
opinions of h agents
on the left are the two dynamics using
generated from different initial
conditions on the right are the
estimated dynamics that's the one we
learn from the data and then use the
estimator to regenerate the dynamics
this blue dashed line here i mean a
black dashed line here in the middle of
it is the indicate the learning time so
from 0 to 10
that's the chaining time we take this
portion to chain
and then we learn and then predict okay
so as you can see we can at least up to
the learning time we have pretty close
resemblance with the true dynamics and
even prediction of the number at large
time to prediction of the number of
clusters we actually have a high
agreement with that okay
and for this row this is generally for a
totally different initial conditions not
only we can get really high accuracy
with producing the dynamical dynamics we
also have can predict the last time
behavior of this dynamics so this is the
true dynamic versus the external
dynamics okay
oh to answer the question the chest yes
uh for for the time in the dynamics the
final terminal dynamics we uh is it's
not really uh actually independent
variables but rather is like a a a
uh we want to have the amount of we want
to have first is a really short period
of time okay so let's say which can only
uh observe the number custom for really
short period of time and also we want
the dynamic system to be as mixing as
possible that means that the pairwise
data is as
many as many different points as
possible okay so here's the example
is yes and no to the to the questions in
the chat room in the chat window okay so
here's a comparison between the two
interaction kernel to the learn
interaction kernel the black one is a
true interaction kernel the blue one is
the learn interaction kernel we do not
assume that the kernel is compactly
supported we also do not assume the this
point of this continue knowledge of the
point of this continuity we learn all of
this from data and we can actually
approximate this part of this continuity
really well okay well we can also learn
this complex support from the
true
from just the data about this true
interaction kernel and in the background
this is the comparison of the uh
distribution of the power distance okay
so we can see we actually learn over
that okay
so now we know that we have a learning
theory that we will have the
fee hat the estimate of our interaction
kernel converging to the fee at about 1d
regression rate and we guarantee that
the linear system generated
uh
yes for that we have a real data uh
example for that yes and then we have
guarantee of that uh linear system being
well conditions now the next question is
can we actually extend these two various
different dynamic systems the first one
is about can i actually handle a system
of heterogeneous agents where agents of
different type so for example this
dynamical system i have a single
predator chasing a group of prey and we
are able to learn that dynamical system
for four different kinds of interaction
kernels and we can predict the behavior
of the predator pretty well also uh the
group of priests is also good okay so
again on the left are the true dynamics
on the right are the learn dynamics and
if they're on the same road they share
the same initial conditions so here's
the behavior of this uh two types of
agents dynamical system a single
predator chasing a group of rays and
because of that we'll learn a total of
four different interruption kernels
this one is the prey on plain
interaction kernel this is the predator
on prey this is the prey on predator and
this is the predator on predator
interaction kernel because we only have
one single interaction uh predator so
the predator and predator kernel have no
data we cannot learn it from the data so
it's actually learned as zero okay and i
want to point out the uh predator and
prey interaction kernel and the prey on
predator interaction kernel these two
kernels share the same interaction uh
data it's the same pair of distance data
but we're able to learn it as you can
see the distribution uh roughly the same
okay we're able to learn it
totally different behavior not negative
of each other it's a totally different
behavior of this two kernel okay so we
can actually do that
from this particular two phrase
dynamical system
uh we can also extend this system to a
second order system so we only talk
about a first order system we can also
do second order we can also study the
last time behavior of our estimated
dynamical system okay as it turns out we
have conducted several studies on this
as it turns out it actually preserved
the qualitative behavior so for example
this is the fish milling dynamical
system that i talk about so the fish
will swing in this freckle shape and in
fact this is a double milling example so
half of them will swing clockwise the
other half will swing counterclockwise
so let me show the movie oh
so don't stop
so initially they are at
chaotic states and if i let the runtime
run eventually half of them will swing
compromise the other half with internet
colors and the exact same thing happens
for this uh
learn dynamics too although not exactly
at the same
number of ages oh no no at the same ages
but the same number of regions will do
the same thing okay so we actually have
a check to to check this lunchtime
behavior okay so we have that and the
next is about these flocking dynamics
this one is a little bit um
a little bit a little bit more difficult
uh uh no number three more complicated
than the original cooking smell flocking
dynamics the quickest smell flocking
dynamics the birds will anticipate and
not anticipate will have the position
current position of the neighboring
birds and they will flock which means
that they will fly in the same velocity
at the last time they in this case this
birds will anticipate the neighboring
birds at the future
position so they do not do it at current
time at future time and if they do that
they will not fly at the same direction
wide awake rather than they will fly
around a center max
center mass velocity directions and kind
of circle around there for a lifetime
and then eventually fly at the same
velocity so let me show you a movie
about this anticipated flocking dynamics
as you can see uh all for these uh for
these learn dynamics we can actually
not only the exact positions but also
the lifetime behavior of these flocking
of birds so
instead okay so these are the second
order dynamical systems that we can
learn now the next uh natural questions
would would be if i have the agents
constrained on a spherical ball or other
kind of lenovo manifolds can i still
learn these uh dynamical system or the
interaction kernel from this data okay
as it turns out yes so originally i have
that the parallel distance depends only
on euclidean distance okay because i'm
in the euclidean space if i'm on a
manifold i need to change that to
geodesic distance
that's what we want to do and simplify
it i have that the change
of my state
if these things are constrained on
renault and manifold it's still an
average sum of the
pairwise fueled as a distance
based on these states on rimmonia
manifold i have i have to know that my
ammonia manifold and its uh
metric in order to compute the geodesic
distance okay and my interruption kernel
is just the parallax duty of the
paralysis potential and this directions
i put a restriction on that in order to
have a existing uniqueness of my
dynamical system okay basically it's
just flow into the geodesic tangential
directions if the points is in the is
not in the uh uh cut loader sets if it's
in the color cell we have to set it to
zero in order to preserve continuity
okay
so in order to learn from this dynamical
system constraint on remodeling and
manifolds we need to have respect the
geometry so we design the norm the air
functional using the
using the remaining metrics that is
given to me basically doing that i can
actually obtain the same memory rate as
if they are actually living in euclidean
space i can also show the convergence of
the estimated dynamics to the true
dynamics within the learning time
interval that's the number of initial
conditions going to infinity okay so now
i assure you this group of agents
constrained on a 2d sphere in this case
still a single predator chasing a group
of prey so they would chase them into
the north or the south pole okay again
on the left are the true dynamics on the
right are the
learned dynamics
if they're on the same road they share
the same initial conditions
another thing is the reason why we want
to assume the learning of this
particular form is that if we learn the
interaction kernel is really easy for us
to do transfer learning when i say
transfer learning is if i learn from
these agents or this system of 20 agents
i will be able to transfer this
learning result to a system of 40 agents
or even 80 agents right away because i
learned the interaction kernel which is
independent of the number of agents in
the system and also independent of the
initial conditions okay so i can do that
so the third rule shows you the transfer
learning results from our learning
framework we can handle this rather easy
and
also we can maintain a pretty good
relative accuracy in predicting the
trajectories okay so because we have a
total of two types of agents we have a
total of four different interaction
kernels to learn and in this case we can
actually learn this really well okay
and this is a a predator chasing group
of three constrained to a point quicker
disc example
so they are actually following the
pancreatic magic okay
hyperbolic metro sorry
okay again we can do the chance for
learning and we can preserve this uh uh
behavior especially the predator
behavior really well okay
in fact uh for the program this we
actually need better than those agents
constrains constraints
to this field okay so this is the
example
okay so the next one so we we learned
all of this on simulate the data the
next question the general question is
can we handle actual real data
application so we try on the selection
mechanics so um
so our goal is not to
we dis well we are to discover what
newton did but our goal is we want to
let the computer do this we want to let
the computer reading the input data and
speed out the newton's law of gravity
okay without telling it that the the
trajectory is elliptical the tutorial
closed the laws satisfy certain or form
no just tell them it is a caroline
interactions agent-based model tell me
the kernel the potential the gravity
potential that actually explains this
data okay
uh let me answer the quick quick ques
the questions in the chat real quick so
uh for the manifold we we we we do not
well yeah we we kind of know that the
manifold and the magic in some sense so
we do assume we know the we have uh
adequate knowledge of the manifold uh
and
we haven't tried to
to use my search space depending on the
manifold yet
uh uh
so we are looking into that so for now
we actually have
have adequate amount of knowledge of the
manifold and we don't we assume we know
everything we can parameterize it
and then just that the um
the known depends on the manifold in
some sense yes okay
uh yeah and also that will take more
complications all right let me go i mean
i mean yeah when you
answer the questions to the
to the
the chat in in the chat
uh if you can read that question first
and then answer that would be
very helpful because not not everyone
has the access to the chat room oh okay
i'm sorry about that yes yeah yeah
let me towards the end i answer all of
this together okay so uh yeah so uh so
uh for this uh uh selection mechanics
examples so we want to learn that the
interactions between the sun and all the
major planets in the solar system we're
gonna ignore the extra belts the two
extra belts and then
we're going to just do the interaction
between the sun and a major planet and
also the moon of the earth because this
moon earth certain story by the system
has been well studied so we want to you
want to know that okay
and um
yes okay so uh in order to for us to
actually explain this we want to uh
extend our first order dynamical system
the framework to second order so we're
going to assume this so-called
lagrangian is the sum of the kinetic
energy minus the potential energy and
again we're going to assume that the
potential energy is the sum of the
pairwise potential okay and it has a
different form so here i'm i'm going to
assume that my state actually has the
position and the velocity okay so the
parent potential is going to be
different between each agent so it's
going to be
has the mass information and some other
information enclosed in this in this uh
inter potential kernel okay so using the
lagrangian equation relationship i have
that the
basically just the second newton's
second law comes out the total uh
momentum is just the total uh
gravitational forces times by the times
the directions okay
and then i have i have basically put
that put it back into first order
dynamical system form that the change of
my velocity is the average sum but in
this case because each pair of agents
are different so i don't have the one
oven there depending on the power
distance whether by the pairwise uh
displacement in these agents okay
so in this case i'm going to assume that
my power this parallel interaction
kernels has the mass information
enclosed in there okay it's not gonna
well i'm not gonna assume that when i
know this i'm gonna just assume that the
pairwise interaction kernel between each
agent is different okay
so in order i'm gonna learn a total n
square interaction kernels all together
okay so yeah so first i'm going to test
it on simulated data i'm going to test
it on a celestial mechanics with
newton's gravity okay and we know that
the newton's gravity is just the youth
and second node that the general
universal gravity follows this form okay
i'm going to assume that i have absolute
space time because right now we cannot
deal with second order remainder
manifold yet and i'm going to assume the
initial mass is the same thing as
gravitational mass so that i can cancel
out these two masses and i'm going to
also assume because we're using absolute
space time that gravity will have in
immediate actions at every single planet
right away okay so now i can simplify it
i can simplify the initial mass and
gravitational mass on both sides and
also put this
this term here over so that i have the
gmi prime over rq form instead of the
original r squared form okay and then
i'm going to assume that these
interaction kernels are all different
and they only depend on power distance
so
and i'm not going to given the mass of
each planet and also not the sun i'm not
going to assume that a particular
geometry for my uh
trajectories i'm going to similarly
point wise
observation of my trajectories and i'm
only going to assume my power distance
is different for each planet planet or
planet sun interactions but it depends
on paradise and data so that's the only
knowledge i have but i need to
learn a total of n square
interaction kernels for a system
for one observation of the system okay
so here's the result of learning uh over
the inner solar system i have the sun
and uh five other planets okay but this
is simulators so i can i'm allowed to
generate it with different initial
conditions for the actual solar system i
cannot okay so i have that
and and as you can see the left are the
true dynamics the right are the learn
dynamics the two offer really close
assembling with each other even with the
coloring okay
and in fact i can learn a total of 25
uh interaction kernels at the same time
over
uh the same observation of the whole
system and this is the
planning on sun interactions this is the
sun planet interactions i can
learn the planet on sun and sun on
planet interaction really well
some of these interplanetary
interactions like for example this mile
on mercury
and this is the mazon uh
mercurial mass interaction kernel i
cannot learn them that well because they
are well below the numerical
accuracy for single position data and
also this earth on mercury is not that
good but some of the others i can learn
them well as long as they are above 10
to the negative 10
scale okay but that's just that's just
uh the numerical errors that's that is
uh uh
inheriting the data but if you look at
just the first row and also first column
i have the planet on sun interaction
kernel and certain planet interaction
kernel
then if you look at these especially say
for example the mercury on certain
interaction kernel and sun or mercury
the two behave roughly the same
except maybe a different type a length
scale
okay so this is ten to negative nine
this is ten to negative two but they
they they decay roughly the same way
okay so that points out that maybe
there's a hidden information behind
these estimators of these uh kernels
that we can actually decouple from it so
we decouple the information of the
newton's form remember as one over our
cube because we switch a little bit okay
from these estimated kernels
and it fits really well to the described
new transform and we're able to extend
that to a continuous function even
at a really really large disjoint domain
okay
and out of that we did couple the one of
our q form from the introduction kernel
as well as the message from the
interaction kernel so we can learn the
individual sun and individual planets
methods from our learning estimator and
we can maintain at least a two digit
accuracy at estimating them
okay so we have that
okay
so now we learn pretty good for uh
similar data so so the next thing would
be can i actually do it for uh uh real
data so we take it
to this nasa's
data that we actually take it off the
horizon uh website okay and it's been
developing by now it's been developed by
nasa over since 1980s and it's really
accurate
and um
and well it
it's considered synthetic data but it's
actually really close to the true
observation data so we take it as the
true observation data okay so we will
take the sun as i said before eight
major planets and the moon of the earth
because we want to study the three body
problem we will take 500
years of daily only daily position and
velocity data from 1500 to 1999 and
we'll use that to
learn the estimator and then use the
estimator to estimate the trajectories
or reproduce the trajectories and in
order to to keep the system uh stable we
will use a sympathetic integration in
order to be able to integrate over 500
years of data okay and once we obtain
the trajectories we use it to estimate
its geology the geometric property of
this to study the period the perihelion
and helium and once we know that we can
actually preserve these geometric
properties we study the really highly
sensitive perihelium procession rate of
our trajectory data okay and then we
also will compare our result to newton's
stimulation and also to the einstein
inferior hofmann systems
this in isolating hormone system is a
first-order approximation of the general
relativity
theory okay
so here's the result the comparison
between the earth moon sun system of the
gpl is the observation data we take from
the gpr database ld is the one that we
learned from the jpl data and also
reproduce it using synthetic integration
eih
is the
similar data for the einstein infra
hoffman system also using uh
no this is the fully implicit uh
integrator using manus integrator and
the newton's is using a sympathetic
integrator as you can see this four
system
if you look at it using eyeball node
they offer
no major differences okay so we can
actually preserve this property over a
large time
okay using our integrator
and then this is the
inner source system okay so this is the
one taking from the true
observation data okay as you can see our
our uh estimator behave roughly the same
thing as
newtons uh the ih has a way narrow band
for uh this is uh
i think this is
mars okay then what we have for uh for
this uh for this trajectory is we are
actually more similar to newton's
because we use the collective dynamics
framework okay and this is the outer
source system okay and again we behave
roughly the same thing as
as newtons so now we have the eyeball
norms of these trajectories now let's
look at the quantitative analysis of
these errors so we take this
position and velocity data and then we
compute errors over 450 years and also
another 500 years okay and we do
comparison of this
uh the blue ones the the light and dark
blue ones are the ones from our own
learning dynamical system the light and
dark red ones are from the einstein
system the light and dark yellow ones
are from the newton system okay
again i want to mention that we change
from 450 years of data and predict
another 50 years
due to the
limited amount of data that we have okay
as you can see
if we do the prediction of the positions
and velocity over 500 or even 450 years
or 500 years our accuracy actually beat
overall beat einstein and newton okay
in terms of just position and velocity
at each time
at the
time instance
prediction we can also
study the geometric properties of the
trajectories we can estimate the period
out of this trajectories we're able to
actually learn the period really well
except at the neptunes and neptunes okay
and with that we can also study the
athenium and perihelium which is the
closest and furthest further away
position of merc off your planet with
sun okay we do it really bad with
mercury but beside that everything else
we do really good and for the perihelium
we also
a little bit
worse than the newtons and einsteins
okay but we're doing really good for all
the others okay
and here is a comparison of the
interruption kernels now this time to to
tell you that we are doing okay to the
interaction kernel we compare it to
newton's gravity so the black line
through the middle is the relative
errors of newton's gravity so if we are
close to the black line in the middle we
are close to newtons okay the gray
background is the range of the einstein
interactions the einstein interactions
does not depend only on power distance
it also depends on
speed pairwise velocity and also
acceleration so it has a projected range
over that okay as you can see uh the
blue dashed line is the one that we
learned is the relative errors that we
learned we can actually
maintain this range in between
the newtons and the einstein range
for each for most of the planet on
certain sun on planet interactions
because that's the major ones that's the
one govern the actual movement of the
solar system okay
and this is the sun on planet
interaction kernel again in the gray
background is the range of the einstein
interactions the black one the black
solid one through zero is the actual
newtons okay
as you can see as once we get small to
below 10 to negative 10
the numerical error kicks in with no
hope of learning this that accurate okay
but we're able to learn the plan
decouple these planet on sun interaction
kernel from the system from learning
from this system of data really well
okay
and because we can reproduce the
position we produce the velocity the
period the feeling para hidden that well
we're also looking into the most
sensitive perihelion perception rate
okay i want to mention that the the uh
the trajectories of my data mouse data
is actually used in the discovery of the
newton's universal law of gravitation
okay so once it's like the the typical
newton's planet the perihelion
perception rate of mercury that's the
one explained by einstein's general
relativity theory so you need a
relativity effect term in order to
actually predict that we do not have
that but we're able to actually predict
pretty close to that using a general
form of this parallel distance okay in
mundo moon because one is small is
really
really highly sensitive to perturbation
you actually need a lunar theory no no
perturbation theory to explain the
movement okay but we're able to actually
incorporate all of this perturbation
inside our power distance kernel
and actually to learn that and produce a
really high
accurate
pair hidden possession rate to do that
so
um you need three different theories to
explain all these three movement uh our
learning dynamics uh
learning framework can do that in one
framework in one uniform framework okay
so that computer can can explain this
selection mechanics movement okay
so that's that okay
so yeah again uh for simulated data
we're able to decouple and find the
knowledge of the mass and and and and
also the uh the form of my pairwise
distance interactions okay for this the
actual data we can also do that so we go
back and we change the uh decoupling
position and then still obtain at least
a two digit right of accuracy in
estimating the masses we do not know the
mass when we actually learn the
dynamical system okay
and also the coupled format are really
close to newton which explains why we
actually behave both a long newton
because we're actually
getting a really like a newton's kernel
okay due to the restriction of that
kernel okay
okay so that's that so we can actually
handle real data if
we actually
taking a consideration of all the
different dynamical
system and different uh hidden
parameters in it we can actually use it
to actually discover the extra physical
quantities so next thing is i've been
talking about that the parallel distance
kernel that the kernel depends on parent
distance but in fact you can have a
general kernel that depends only on
pairwise state
but if you do that this is a high
dimensional function it's really
difficult to learn so we use a reduced
uh feature map techniques to actually
learn the feature map first and then
learn the interaction kernel and here's
an example of comparing the uh
so v1 is the one that we do not know the
feature map v2 is the one that we do
know the feature map as you can see we
actually read uh
in terms of errors that uh that our
regression actually is better than
knowing the feature map okay so here's a
comparison of the trajectories
um
we can just for learning and learning
really well and then this is a 2d
example when this feature map is
actually
2d function instead of a
yeah
okay
and we can also do this just for
learning really well so that's the first
example that we do not know the feature
map we don't know if the interaction
kernel depends on power distance it
might depends on something else we can
use a
dimension reduction technique to
actually learn that okay the next step
is what if i only had one snapshot of
the dynamical system okay so before i
have several snapshots in fact i have a
large amount of snapshots okay what if
the dynamical system was in reach is
steady state and only take one time okay
if i do that i need to use a
some kind of inverse problem regulation
from rkhs to actually help me to find
the kernel up to a scaling scaling
factor
that
if i'm giving a steady state of this
dynamical system i can learn the
interaction kernel after scaling factor
really close to the original one so if
if i only
give me one snapshot i can still learn
but this is up to the scaling factor
okay so that's the two ongoing project
we finished the feature map learning
already so we're looking into this
uh steady state learning okay
so that's that so there are some other
things so we finished the first order
learning on the future map so we're
looking to the second order examples
especially when the second order have
both the flocking and uh and other
milling behavior altogether we also
looking into this rkhs learning example
how to use the kernel we actually all of
this dynamical system actually has its
own kernel and own reproducing kernel
how can we use that to actually do
denoising how can we actually use it to
give us a better basis a such space to
find the solutions and and sexual hex
etc and we're also looking into how to
learn on dynamics constrained on remonum
and second order dynamics constraining
on remodeling manifolds okay
and we always look at real data
applications because we want to know if
our learning framework can be applied to
real actual data okay
and uh we're also looking into how to
expand these these models these
collected uh behavior models uh for
example how can i actually extend the
model so that it will actually generate
locus warming because local swarming is
a little bit more more different than
flocking okay and all this different
stuff and um i've been i've been talking
about that the uh the state change of
the state vector is an average sum but
uh birds cannot do calculation it will
not know average sum so it should be a
topological
averaging it only knows those
roughly locally neighboring to to the
birds so we're looking into topological
averaging and so the you know instead of
the total averaging
and also uh when when the number of
agents going to thin they want to
understand the mean field limit and how
to learn them well okay we're also
looking into some pde related problems
that is derived from this self-organized
dynamics meaningful games etc and all of
this okay
uh so here's a references okay so this
is the four approach we use
uh this one that's the one for the
fishermen example we use this for
flocking this is the photo text example
but we didn't show it and then we have
this is the predator chasing the google
play example that we use
and then we have the anticipation
dynamics and also the opinion dynamics
that we use so this is the papers that
we use for generating all these
dynamical data
and here is the paper
the references on the learning framework
that we have been building up so we
start off from this first paper that
amounted with this group of germans
people on on how to
learn the interaction kernel when the
number of agents go to infinity
and then this is our first paper on
extending that but fix the number of
agents rather than letting the number of
agents go into infinity we think about
number of
different initial conditions going to
infinity
and then we look at the launch time
behavior of our estimated dynamics and
all of this different stuff
available online you can look them up
and then and yeah that's it um any uh
uh
thank you for the great presentations
uh we'll have a training session uh
i'm sure the pat is going to be um very
active in training sessions so do yeah
pat do you want to engage directly
i'm sorry about that
so i yeah i asked a lot of questions you
don't have to answer them all we can
take them offline uh okay but
i mean we have a way to record to record
the questions or do any we need to cut
and paste them
um
record what do you mean i mean it's it's
being recorded right now the text box
okay i'll i'll
i'll grab them so so but uh but thank
you this was really i mean i find this
fascinating work this is great um but
the thing that i'm most confused about
is what exactly what you mean by an
interaction kernel and how
and and so and and how you use it so so
in machine learning
uh at least as we defined it back in the
1980s you can't talk about learning
until you talk about the performance
module that uses the learned
models
and you have really not told us about
that because we and you have to talk
about the representation so so
the interaction kernel sometimes you
show a curve sometimes you show
equations
i i don't know what they mean and i
don't know how you use them to predict
behavior so without talking about
learning
or discovery can you just talk about the
kernel and how it's used to make to
generate predictions
oh yes yes so the kernel is is this guy
the function that gives me the the
change
into the state vector so this this guy
this interaction function here
you could you show up a pic
one of the early slides you had and you
had you had curves and i didn't
understand how the interaction kernel
was a curve
oh uh hold on uh so
so let's go back to the comparison uh
let me see so
you
this kernel is that how is that yes how
is that an equation
well this is this because the
interaction kernel depends on pairwise
data so it's actually just a 1d function
it depends on it
what is this a function of because the
font is pretty small
oh
sorry uh is hey let me zoom in so this
is a function of r which is a power
interaction uh variable so it's just a
distance
function it's a function of distance the
x-axis is the distance and what's the
y-distance
y-axis is like the strength like how
much
how much interactions you would exalt uh
give based on this distance okay so this
is a highly non-linear function and
that's okay and you and and you estimate
the shape
uh i estimated this from the dynamical
data so this yeah and us but you assume
that uh you assume that the uh that that
us all the agents of a particular class
have the same kernel
exactly with the same
graph here
with the same parameters
well uh
this would be at the same kernel because
they are the same type if they are at
the same time they will have sync kernel
uh if there are different types they
will have different kernels but not
depends on parameters depending on
but not but not not different
not different not the same shape but
different parameters the actual same
curve here would everything the same
type would have this kernel
yes at the same time we'll have this
kind of yeah okay so in the in case of
of the gravitational attraction in in
the planetary in the solar system
uh i assume that the kernel does not
look like this it's actually much
simpler is that true
yeah yeah it is uh so for the um sorry
let me go back to
the uh
uh the
in the gravity of stars here
so
with that the kernel will look like this
thank you and so
and it's no easier but you're saying
it's and that and that could be
described parametrically with a closed
form equation but you're not assuming
that
no it's a you you could imagine a
version of your approach that only works
with parametric equations and then that
would presumably be even
even more
computer computationally efficient
yes yes if if i assume if i have more
prior knowledge of this yes we're
actually looking into this so-called
semi-parametric learning
that we have some kind of parametric
structure
and that will help us sure learn that
fasting and i can imagine piecewise
linear or piecewise parametric versions
of these two but but in general
it could be arbitrary
and you said it's a function of distance
but distance of course isn't the only
that's that assumes that you're talking
about three-dimensional motion um this
approach obviously is not going to be
limited to that i could imagine applying
it to other dynamical systems like in
chemistry
where
where the dimensions are very different
uh yes yes in fact if i uh
there was a 2d example that i show
this this flocking here uh anticipation
flocking dynamics here it not only
depends on power distance it's also have
a
paris uh heading
the heading is also taking into account
so that it will actually revolve instead
of going straight yeah all right so look
i think this is great work i'm really
excited about it but let me encourage
you because this is novel at least to me
that you spend more time in future talks
explaining this up front because
i okay
it's alien the notion of a kernel of
course has been around in machine
learning for 30 years but yes
but the notion of an interaction kernel
is that is that has that been in the
literature or is that a new idea
if this is a new idea we've been pushing
something yes then then you should spend
more time on it that's it okay i'm sorry
yeah yeah okay i will do that yeah yeah
thank you
wonderful
is there any other questions from
audience
i guess you know the path asked a lot
more questions but i guess if we can go
you know offline for those questions
yeah i'm sorry about jumping about this
question so
yeah no worries no worries yeah
all right i don't see any questions um
so so so is there any other work on on
learning models of collective behavior
not your approach but other approaches
to doing this uh you can so um uh the
thing is you can actually do it using a
new network you can think of uh you can
just fit so for example like oh you can
use it you can i i'm sure you could yeah
my question is have people actually done
that is there a literature on learning
collective behaviors
by whatever method by by some other
method yes for example they actually did
fit it using neural network and then and
then but they didn't do the predictions
they only talk about the regression of
this function okay so you can do that
use a neural network yeah and i'm sure
you can use things other than neural
nets i'm not a big fan of neural nets
personally yeah
yeah well what our approach is we not
only learn the interaction kernel we
also learned the feature map which is
the feature is shared around all the
dynamical systems it's just the
interaction might be different okay so
we want to learn the feature yeah thank
you
all right sounds good
well if there's no further questions
then we can um you know thank our
speaker for the great talk
and um
i'm sure
we have learned a lot and if the if
there's a further questions um
you guys can reach out to me directly
and he will be happy to answer and any
questions you guys have write me yep yep
okay wonderful and and with this talk
i'm i hope that
there will be future collaborations um
you know among us um
that would be wonderful okay thank you
thank you
okay with that we will conclude that uh
the seminar today all right thank you
everyone thank you